[Applaus]
heute ist weltweiter aktionstag für den
klimaschutz und in deutschland haben in
rund 160 städten demonstrationen
kundgebungen und aktionen stattgefunden
ich stehe ja an der alten oper in
frankfurt und vier findet heute die
zentrale kundgebung statt
warstein
die stimmung ist insgesamt friedlich das
schöne wetter die platte
sind aber eben nicht nur jugendlichen
gekommen
freitags demos sind diesmal auch viele
erwachsene dabei es geht nämlich nicht
weniger als darum die welt zu wenden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier am brandenburger tor hat es eine
kundgebung gegeben zu der wohl mehr als
100000 teilnehmern gekommen sind die für
klimaschutz eingetreten sind
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit als hier die menschen
demonstrierten haben die politiker der
großen koalition ein maßnahmenpaket
vorgestellt mit dem thema schutzpaket
machen wir jetzt ernst und dabei wird
ein neuer weg beschritten der viele
viele aspekte umfasst da geht es zb
meine ticketsteuer auf flugreisen die
wir weiter ausbauen und gleichzeitig
möglich zu machen des bahn- tickets
billiger werden
da geht es zum beispiel eine reform der
kfz-steuer die dazu beiträgt dass ein
hoher co2 verbraucht sich auch in einer
höheren kfz-steuer dieter steht die
koalition hat sich mit diesem
maßnahmenpaket sehr zufrieden gezeigt
und es wird eine menge geld kosten 54
milliarden euro haben die koalitionäre
ausgerechnet auf der anderen seite haben
sich die umweltverbände frei des future
die grünen mit diesen maßnahmen paket
sehr unzufrieden gezeigt der co2 preis
sei ein schlag ins gesicht von
hunderttausenden demonstranten hat eine
sprecherin von frey des future gesagt
die bundeskanzlerin hat diesen kritikern
sozusagen schon vorbeugend auf der
pressekonferenz geantwortet
riesig ist dass es die dass das was
möglich ist und die möglichkeiten sie
haben wir ausgelotet und das sei der
unterschied zu den forderungen der
oft ungeduldigen jungen menschen die sie
sagte papa mit diesem tag und mit diesem
maßnahmenpaket wird die klima
streikbewegung in deutschland nicht zu
ende gehen sondern sie wird mit großer
sicherheit weiter gehen und
möglicherweise sogar noch stärker werden
[Musik]